bonjour bonjour et bienvenue bienvenue
sur des modèles tv pour ce championnat
du monde féminin sotchi 2015 avec les
toutes meilleures joueuses du monde qui
seront présentes qui sont présentes pour
ce titre mondial on a un pic onéreux ou
bien entendu on a aussi alexandra
kosteniuk et a gagné le titre on a en
toile et à stefano va aussi qui a été
championne du monde qu'akram ling on à
tatiana kosintseva on à irin a crush
l'américaine on a aussi bien sûr et bien
la délégation chinoise qui est nombreuse
sauf ifan rouillé fanou meilleure
joueuse du monde qui joue pas ce
championnat du monde de femina cette
année mais qui on le voit a fait un
parcours 2014 extraordinaire avec
notamment sa victoire aux corses icahn
circuit exceptionnel victoire un
championnat où le champion du monde l'ex
champion du monde de vichy va
l'atteindre à nantes s'était fait
éliminer en demi-finale et où la
chinoise avait vaincu est bien celui qui
avait fait tomber un hand fait leur truc
en finale par le score de 2 0 donc les
filles qui maintenant joue au tout
meilleur niveau mondial dans la foulée
des soeurs pôle gare
on a aussi bien entendu dans ce
championnat du monde des biens des
françaises deux françaises deux ex
championne de france on à sophie millet
qui est présente et puis aussi notre
grand maître international national
meilleures joueuses de tous les temps en
france marie sebag mari qui aussi vient
à sotchi et pas pour faire de la
figuration sans doute donc on va suivre
bien entendu sur des modèles tv
d'abord et avant tout danser danser tour
de championnat du monde les françaises
en espérant qu'elle aille le plus loin
possible et pourquoi pas en finale et on
va faire un petit résumé de cette
première ronde qui voit s'opposer
notamment alors dans le premier match
qu'on va voir en résumé santé on va voir
les moments importants de ce match enfin
pas tous les coulées sur ce serait trop
long surtout qu'on va voir deux parties
puisque on va voir you've en face à
marie sebag et puis dans l'autre partie
est bien l'américaine irina trucks qui
est multiple championne des états unis
et qui joue face à l'ex championne de
france sophie millet donc un match de
deux championnes
là aussi très intéressant donc on va
voir dans cette première partie
comment your band joue face à un mari
c'est baky donc à les noirs c'est parti
donc avec les premiers coups on va voir
l'ouverture et bien c'est eux quatre et
c5 pour marine sicilienne qualif trois
des six des quatre pions prend cavaliers
prend 4,6 calais c3 et a6 alors là ici
le choix pour les noirs de la fameuse
des variantes donc fou est 3e 5 alors
très agressif de la part démenti le coup
et cinq questions lecavalier mais
affaibli la casse des 5 voilà donc on va
dérouler ici les cookies sont connus le
fou sort logique en contrôler la casse
des cinq très jolie case naturel est ce
une façon originale de traiter ces
variantes avec h3 pour les blancs
empêche le fou devenir un des quatre où
le cavalier aussi pour ne peut pas
attaquer le fou alors c'est intéressant
puisque après il faut 7 les blancs jouve
dame f3 à l'enam f3 si on avait joué h3
on pouvait se heurter plus tard à fou
j'ai 4
qui à contrôler la casse d un donc ça
empêche chez aurait le grand roque ou si
on faisait grand roque ça prendrait à
tour donc le courage 3 on voit bien et
logique avec l'idée d'un f3 donc petit
roque et lage et 4 pourquoi pas mélanger
4 ça veut dire qu'on joue vraiment pour
le grand roque alors pourquoi pas
l'avoir fait tout de suite mon g4
pourquoi pas c'est tendu on voit que les
joueuses ici sont agressives alors très
intéressant ce coup voilà un moment
important de la partie puisque les noirs
joué le coup à cinq on vient de le voir
et puis ce coup et bien menace de venir
en a quatre attaquants bien sûr le
cavalier b3 et puis aussi venant
potentiellement jusqu'en à 3 pour casser
la structure des pions blancs et
perturber un grand roque éventuel donc
attention ce coût est tendue il est
surprenant qu'il est il n'est pas
habituel puisqu'on a joué deux fois la
même pièce à 6 puis à 5
c'est parce que les blancs n'ont pas
continué une action au centre direct n'y
fait le petit rock donc il est logique
de pouvoir s'affaiblir de ce côté là où
dans tout cas de lancer une attaque
puisque on voit mal comment les blancs
mais non pourrait faire petit rock après
avoir joué h3g 4 et donc au rayon roi un
tout petit peu quand même qui serait un
tout petit peu faible potentiellement
faible donc le grand roque est injouable
pourquoi pas attaqué directement le côté
dames poule b 5
voilà le fou contrôler la casa 4 logique
cavalia si ce très joli coup là pour les
noirs de développement à noter que le
pion à 5 et protégé dans la dame des 8
même si le tunnel et b3 un oeil dessus
et puis on va venir à ces sept titiller
ce cavalier se fout pardon et cavale et
prend ensuite après calais prend pour
jouer à 4 à 3 toujours et casser la
structure blanche et les blancs n'aurait
plus que leurs yeux pour pleurer avec
une position faible des deux côtés donc
grand roque
pas de problème pour l'instant et
cavaliers c7 donc menace câblée
prendrait cinq ans lève une protection
sera 4 et à 4 à 3
monsieur mais on menace de gagner le
fourbe et 5 les noirs les blancs laisse
pas faire il vous faut b6 publicis cloud
cavaliere alors la très jolie coup
encore une fois de marie qui en jonque
alexis c'est bien on enlève tout venait
à l'attack g5 cgi ne sera plus possible
on enlève un protecteur de décès mais on
attaque le foot b6 le fou b5 et en
attaque et les blancs doivent se
délester d'un fou et après fou prend
d'emprunt belle et noir ont la fameuse
paire de fou un mine de rien donc
attention en finale la paire de fou pour
s'avérer forte donc il faut que les
blancs garde une position semi fermée
jusqu'à ce que les choses soient soient
plus claires à 4 alors à 4 c'est une
façon radicale d'empêcher la manoeuvre à
4 à 3 c'est fini c'est bloqué bon ça
peut affaiblir un tout petit peu le rock
alors regardez très jolis tours fc 8 on
garde la torah 8 au contact de 1,5 à
noter qu'à 5 heures quand un tout petit
peu emprise du cavaly b3 bon même si la
dame protège ça fait deux défenseurs
c'est pas mal la taux refi de toute
façon n'avait pas de jeu de ce côté là
on va pas jouer 5 1 la les blancs ont
contrôlé est simple donc on joue sur la
colonne c voilà donc regardez comme
c'est important de mettre la bonne tour
on garde une tour ici en sur la colonne
à et puis on met l'autre touchera
colonne sait et on se trompe pas on met
pas la tour à ça c'est les grands
maîtres comme marie qui savent jouer ça
revient et là on regarde est très jolie
alors ça c'est un coup là encore un
qu'il faut il faut savoir jouer ça c'est
pour les noirs calais b si je vise la
case c4 alors à noter qu'en sekkat je
peux y mettre le fou pourquoi pas pour
proposer un échange en b 5 ce qui
affaiblirait à 4 je peux aussi mettre le
cavalier je peux envisager avec un
cavalier en c4 plus tard de prendre b2
et le cas à l'essai trois noms n'aurait
plus de défenseurs comme des pions comme
défenseur donc voilà on pourrait par un
cas les c4 car il prend encore apprendre
la dame encore 1,3 protège mais on voit
que c'est une possibilité à moyen long
terme
cette case c4 est une case d'invasion
pour les noirs alors que les blancs
n'ont pas l'équivalent ils ont pas une
case dans le camp noir là où allez vous
voyez il n'y a pas de quoi il n'y a pas
de poids
disons avancé alors le seul micro la
seule micro compensation communiquons
les blancs c'est la casse des cinq qui
est faible avec le pion des six arriérés
mais tout ça est bien tenu par les deux
fous plus le cas les v6 maintenant
puisqu'il protège des singles à noter
que si les blancs m² d'un dessin on
prend sans doute en d5 et les blancs
sont obligés de en prenant du pillon de
couvrir en couvre la faiblesse c'est
plus une faiblesse que la colonne ne
table plus sur le plan des six
voilà donc on va continuer la partie
dames 2 et la foule s'écarte voilà donc
c'est là c'est l'idée qu'on avait dit a
cassé quatre ont propos on propose des
échanges les noms sont confiants dans le
fait qu'ils ont la colonne c'est que le
pion à 4,26 peu faible on en propose ici
pourquoi pas un échange pourquoi pas fou
contrefout 1 c'est une possibilité
puisque avec quoi prennent les blancs
sylvain prennent avec le pion bien le
pion à 4 à 3 à qui on va très vite que
le roi blanc se retrouve dans les
courants d'air et sous le feu de
l'ennemi
et puis si on prend du cavalier c'est
possible ça attaque la dame une fois que
la dame a joué on a le pion à 4 qui est
en prise voyez ça va vite
donc les blancs prennent et marie
prendre la dame et non pas du cavalier
voilà donc à noter qu'en prenant de la
dame et bien j'attaque à 4 justement
voyez le pion à 4 donc ce coup calais b
6 là aussi inhabituel pas habituel ce
genre de manoeuvres de jouer un coup
comme ça de cavaliers devant un pion
voilà mais en fait ce que ce qu'avait
très très fort au teich des cinq pros
attaque la casse ces quatre attaques le
pion à 4 d'emprunt il a regardé encore
tout reprend voilà tour en place par la
tour ce cavalier magnifique on continue
attaque à 4 et que font les blancs
il n'y a pas de défense à part le couple
en trouver ici un regard décalé d2
j'attaque la tour et la tour doit bouger
si la tour samba ba 4 est protégé par le
cavalier il ya plus deux attaquants
contre lequel le pion non tout va bien
si la toux revient à 4 pour garder
contact
et bien simplement joue b3 et tout est
tenu sur calais prend simplement prendre
carlier et
on a perdu une pièce donc c'est pas une
bonne idée donc voilà donc là il faut
que les noirs s'en aille mais regardez
ce que nous vous marie magnifiques
moments clés de la partie et je suis
allé un peu loin
voilà ici tout reprend cavaliers tout
reprend cavaliers ici simplement on
sacrifie la qualité
magnifique regardez après puis on prend
cavaliers prend 1,4 des pions doublé le
roi dans les courants d'air
un kayak 4 qui en plus attaque le pion
c3 en tombant mal comment le défendra
par le jouet un c4 on faire avancer ses
pions doublé s'est jamais ne s'est
jamais une bonne nouvelle
et puis en plus le pion à 5 il est passé
passé et protégeable en plus par un
deuxième pion donc contre la qualité les
noirs ont d'excellentes compensation
probablement supérieure à la qualité
très jolies manoeuvres de marie sebag
qui montre toute sa place dans cette
partie tout le 1
les blancs ont toujours eu un et bien et
vite cavalli princes et rois avec une
fourchette
car aux atours voilà et mais ça permet
quand même de prendre le pion c3 ou
avait deux cavaliers à quatre échecs roi
trois coups douteux parce que le roi est
sous le feu de l'ennemi du fou notamment
ici même si on attaque le cavalier une
fois que le cas il y aura bougé les
normands la menace des 5 avec fu échec
et puis le pion pourrait venir en d4 par
exemple pourquoi c'est jamais agréable
d'avoir un roi potentiellement en échec
à la découverte s'est jamais une
nouvelles baies 5 en plus les noirs en
profite pour pousser leurs pions pour
ab3 obligé de jouer le roi en b3 bon
pourquoi pas la voir jouer tout de suite
dans ce cas là puisque
ouais ça paraît pas on tue semblerait
que la clau les blancs on fait quand
même une grosse erreur d'appréciation
ici avec ce coup et la tour c 8 toutes
les pièces de marie ces bacs sont en jeu
le cavalier magnifiquement place et ils
contrôlent c3 et b2 le roi blanc est un
tout petit peu aux fraises et qui tour
ces trois menaces avec échec roi de tout
reprend ses deux échecs et le cavalier
des deux îles perdues des pions partout
de pions de plus donc qualité en plus
bon l'avantagent noir il significatif
encore forcément totalement décisif mais
il est fort ces quatre jolis coups ici
un puisqu'en cas de le c4 est protégé
par le cavalier cas de prise du pion et
dans lequel est perdus c'est pas
question donc jouer ces quatre jolis
coups intéressants car les c'est que ces
cinq échecs en c2 et maintenant fou g5
avec un piège si les blancs prennent il
ya évidemment la tour c 8 qui attaquent
le roi donc si on prend en mai cinq
cavaliers prend 2,4 avec échec à la
découverte de la tour euros à bouche et
ensuite cavalier prendre des deux
protégés par le fou g5 et on a gagné une
pièce donc tomber un prêt ont
certainement pas enlever celles qui des
quatre deux pions passé lié et regarder
toutes les cases protégé par les noirs
attaqué par les noirs le fou qui
contrôlent jusqu'en d2 d'ailleurs le
cavalier ici qui contrôle toutes ces
cases et les pions noirs qui contrôlent
ces cases là on est tous ce champ tout
ce champ de protection des noirs et même
la casse des quatre maires et que le
pion blanc ici finalement qui échappe à
l'emprise des noirs regarder le barrage
que l'open bar des comme les blancs sont
étouffés à ça soit visuellement ou tiens
donc c'est la cohue aux échecs il faut
voir plutôt effectivement l'action des
pièces que le que la position des pièces
tôt un cavalier 6 menace de venir en d4
avec un échec
tour d un roi et fuite en maintenant
regarder comme on améliore la dernière
pièce qui jouait par le roi tout est en
action suez chez les noirs et les blancs
sont en défense donc là on va arriver
dans une finale technique
on va accélérer puisque bon
on va pas analyser tous les coups ont
regardé comme marie manner ici londres
manoeuvre pas d'erreur particulière
monde et peut-être peut-être quelques
petites imprécisions techniques m'ont
fait rien de décisif
voilà échec roi le roi bouge et regardez
ici aura noté un qu ici juste pour
revenir sur ce coup là que ici si les
blancs prennent et c'est aux blancs de
jouer les noirs jaunes viennent de jouer
échec au roi avec le cavalier la cie les
blancs prennent en b3 on enlève le
cavalier en prenant f2 et actions de la
tour échec et c'est à la découverte de
la tour et le carrier ensuite prendre à
la tour d un avec une finale et deux
pions de plus en finale deux tours c'est
archi gagnant de surtout de pions liés
même de piau mise au lycée souvent
gagnant mais deux pions lié encore plus
3 b 5 b 2-3 c6 très bien les noirs les
blancs quand même et c'est quelque chose
et le roi a été repoussée mais il va
revenir au centre par la bande il peut
pas venir ici l'an dernier en c5 ni en
c4 ni en b cas puisqu'ils à lecavalier
qui contrôle les deux cases et le pion
dessin l'objet de faire le tour c'est ce
que font les blancs et en même temps se
rapproche du roi noir on peut menacer
des petites choses on peut enfermer le
rendement à l'empêcher d'avancer un
convoi pas le roi est une pièce cruciale
en finale il faut pas hésiter à le
mettre en jeu parce que le camp qui
utilise son roi aura davantage sur le
camp qui l'utilisent pas un don qui la
tension au final le roi est une pièce
d'attac tourbe et 7 g 6,6 à l'équidé
pourquoi pas f5 et on a des pions lier
la carence
qui font qu'ils font le tour donc ici
roi des seuils très intéressant on
menace de venir en quatre attaques la
tour et le cavalier sachant que ce cas
est déjà attaqué par la tour donc
attention c'est dangereux donc mari est
vite sa tour par trois ménages sur
quatre on jouera simplement cavaliers
ces cinq échecs croit bouge et la tour
est perdu avec un 2 pièces donc lâché 5
folique ou secours andes et j'ai marqué
ici
marc contrôler les deux cases sa enferme
le renoir ça on va aller qu'on regardait
comme les blancs essaye de faire tout
pour empêcher le roi noir de venir
participer à la bataille parce que s'il
est blanc essaie de gagner que avec la
toei cavaliers sans que le roi il
participe ça risque d'être difficile
regardez la suite roy g7 quand même pour
le mari ces balles qui va quand même
essayer de faire participer son roi à la
tac toe f1 il faut les protéger aussi le
pion et 2 1 qui était quand même emprise
et elle a simplement regarder h6 voilà
on élimine se purger cinq étaient était
vraiment un poison et anjou h6 je veux
libérer la possibilité pour le roi noir
devenir dangereux qui on prend
évidemment prend pas du roi puisque le
puriste est attaqué par la tour b 7
il y aurait tout reprendre pion et c'est
quand même plus important on prend de la
tour à tour b 3 on revient h3 et la f3
très jolie f3 bages intercepte l'action
donc le cavalier doit bouger et je vais
récupérer un pion le pion aux cinq
essais par ailleurs regardez mari a tout
prévu ici cavalli f4 on va prendre cinq
cavaliers eux deux lecavalier a eu 2 1
as deux choses potentiellement
enfin protège des 4 et puis il peut
menacer aussi devenir en c3 pour menacer
de faire d'un malheur attention le pion
b2 est en prise voilà il est pris et
aura des échecs ici et les blancs ne
peuvent pas venir en 1 4 qu'est ce
qu'ils auraient aimé venir se rapprocher
des pions messi 24 cavalli j'ai trois
échecs roi prend pion par exemple et car
il prend un tour avec une pièce de plus
c'est un pion de plus au final ça ira
trois des six câbles et j3 tombe bien
cavaillé cinq années les manoeuvres
jolie de marie c'est dingue le pion est
attaqué on protège j'avance pour
regarder la suite tour d un ici je
menace pourquoi pas d'avancer le pion
tour ces deux tours 3 échecs 17 et la
tour 3 ans n'a pas peur en cas de prise
probablement prendre du plomb comme ça
on lit les pions les trois pions sont
liés yapluka gober le pion f3 et on voit
mal comment les blancs vont pouvoir le
protéger et alors à trois pions lié avec
un cavalier contre le tour c'est pas la
peine
ça avance tout seul ça rentre comme dans
du beurre c'est facile donc les blancs
ne sont pas contre en échange mais sans
licence le pion isolé si les noirs
prennent ben c'est pas trois pions liés
qu'on a ces deux pions contraint ici il
ya quand il reste une tour puis un pion
isolé ça il ya encore des chances de
nulle la chance deux nuls pour les
blancs c'est d'essayer de sacrifier la
tour qui leur resterait contre le
dernier pion des blancs donc ils vont
actuellement arrive à échanger
un pion contre 2 d'une façon ou d'une
autre avec une erreur des noirs puis de
s'être effet la tour qui resteraient
avec une des deux tours contre le pion
qui est le pion restants mais non les
noirs restent pas enfin ne permettront
pas sa part dont détroit f4 et pourquoi
pas qu'elle ait des quatre attaques la
tour et mélancolie aussi ce le cas les
attaques f4 pour detroit bref c'est un
loyer ça y est le roi vient se mêler à
la bataille
mais le roi blanc aussi y aura des comme
seront a fait le tour voilà qui ont
réussi et est attaqué car les pros f4
roy price est bon pour deux tacles à
tours vient alors à noter ici qu'ils
avaient quand une manoeuvre possible
pour les blancs
c'était de faire tout reprend cavalier
va la regarder
voilà tour 30 cavaliers f4 or on apprend
puis tour prend des trois avec plus que
tour épiant contre tours
cette finale elle est connue comme étant
gagnante pourquoi parce que pour
qu'elles soient nuls fameuse à la
position de philidor que le grand maître
nous a expliqué d'un sont justement son
analyse du jeu d'échecs dont on vous ai
parlé récemment avec sa réédition pour
faire nul dans la position de finhan il
faut que laurent blanc soit 2 voir le
pion il faudrait qu'ils soient là sur
cette case
et dans ce cas là la position serait
nulle dans cette finale mais le roi
blanc étant coupés il ya très loin il
est derrière
parfois souvent les noirs cherche à le
couper par la tour située de l'autre
côté de la barrière mais en fait là il
est même de l'autre côté du roi cirque
il n'est pas du tout dans le bon sens
mais chez le pur d'avancé jusqu'à dames
la tour suffit pas pour l'empêcher
d'avancer voilà il faut que le roi aide
à cette défense
donc là la position est gagnant suffi au
noir de jouer j 5 g 4x et voilà et les
bons peuvent rien faire
ces gagnants
position gagnante donc on revient là
donc il fallait il faut savoir ça
évidemment quand on joue ce genre de
final si l'on ne peut pas espérer faire
nul tour d un g5
on peut pas espérer faire nul pour les
blancs ou gagner pour les noirs si on se
trompe dans le calcul si on connaît pas
ces finales simple d'où l'importance de
connaître les finales tour à 4 tours 5
tour des quatre tours 4 regardez des
manoeuvres encore ici ton des six tout
ça c'est des manoeuvres et ça y est j'ai
sage et 4 c'est l'heure pour les pour
les noirs marie a décidé d'avancer son
pion de plus le pion suffit pas vous
voyez qu'il faut il en faut deux troyens
tour aux trois étoiles 6 et chevronnés
comme les blancs se bat pour essayer de
faire nul est encore possible bien sûr
une erreur des blés des noirs si on
arrive à échanger les deux pions qui
reste contre une tour et bien tour et
cavaliers contre tours eh bien ça ne
gagne pas c'est connu philidor déjà
encore une fois le disait dès le xviiie
siècle
il a démontré que touré fou contre tours
pouvait gagner dans plein position on
sait aujourd'hui que il ya aussi des
positions nul mais qu'en pratique
en pratique c'est extrêmement difficile
à défendre voilà c'est une tour il faut
contre touré est souvent gagnant et même
quand c'est les positions nul c'est très
difficile façon les ordinateurs ayari
mais les humains ont beaucoup de mal à
défendre tous russes contre tours tour
des 6 g iii il faut s'entraîner beaucoup
autour des 8 et là bon ces tours
cavaliers donc ça si nulle part contre
voilà donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
connaître là encore il faut connaître
les finales g2 et voilà regardé comme ce
cavalier magnifique qui contrôle les
deux pions
bon alors ce qu'il est si les blancs
arrivé à certifie une tour contre un
pion puis la deuxième tour prendre le
deuxième pion c'est bon mais ça marche
pas ici tout reprendre et je prends de
la tour pas du cavalier parce que si je
prenais une cavaliers évidemment je
perdais le deuxième plus haut mais je
prends du de la tour et le câble il
continue de protéger et si je prends ce
pion avec cette tournée je peux pas
prendre le deuxième et c'est une
deuxième pion qui va faire la différence
donc il faut empêcher la prise des deux
pions voilà c'est ça le truc autour des
4 alors à noter ici ce roi g4 ça serait
une erreur puisque le cavalier cloud et
on pourrait faire tout reprend échec et
on a perdu un pion alors là par contre
c'est nul c'est sûr il suffirait de
sacrifier la deuxième tour contre le
pion et c'est pas la peine de continuer
tous rétablis contre tours c'est nul
torres 3e set
c'est nul et c'est facile de faire mieux
il n'ya pas difficulté en plus tôt à f2
trois des six essais leur roi g41 marie
veut jouer rage et 3 3 2 c'est fini la
tour f 1 a permis aux cinq tours deux
échecs est le roi est repoussé en état
qu entre 6 et la d2 adélard là c'est
bien parce que la tour protège les deux
pions on ambitionnait qui est pris on
prend de la tour et l'autre est toujours
protégé on peut jamais perdre deux pions
avec cette position là voilà des deux
donc tour des huit à retourner pour
essayer de faire le tour un petit échec
mais est ce que c'est vraiment
intéressant mais pas tellement regardé
mari n'a pas peur cavaliers h3c fini
attaque la tour la force quasiment
sacrifier angers 2e mais dans ce cas-là
ya prise et puis le ceux qui ont fait la
différence et on va la tour alors il
reste tour des quatre échecs wave 3 et
après tour des trois échecs roi évident
aussi fini c'est fini il ya plus
d'échecs et que font les blancs la tour
g1 et attaquer si elle bouge on fait
dames et après tout reprendre cavaliers
granby ceux qui ont fait la différence
au droit
on pourra pas empêcher la dame et chacun
sait que rond et tour contre roye ça
suffit pour faire mal voilà donc la ici
la partie s'arrête
abandons 2 est bien longue
et puis donc victoire magnifique de
marie c'est qu'avec les noirs ce qui est
de très bon augure puisque on sait comme
si difficile de gagner avec les noirs
demain donc mari en deuxième partie aura
les blancs et on peut supposer qu'elle
est quand même favorite de ce premier
tour pour se qualifier donc pour les
seizièmes de finale mais c'est sa
puisqu'elles sont 64 actuellement donc
ce sont les seizièmes de les 32e de
finale actuellement donc si elle gagne
elle passera en 16e voilà donc jolie
victoire on va passer maintenant à la
deuxième partie qui qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui aussi vient bien sûr si la
partie entre deux stars de l'échiquier a
vraiment une star américaine est une
star française puisque c'est irina
croche qui joue donc face à sophie
millet ce 32e de finale de championnat
du monde féminin 2015 à sotchi donc en
russie irina thrush qui est en pleine en
pleine forme en ce moment qui vient en
russie pas pour faire de la figuration
aussi elle est sans doute elle vise très
certainement la finale et sophie millet
qui est bien et c'est de toujours de
faire au mieux sur les compétitions
internationales et pourquoi pas donc
essayer de passer plusieurs tours dans
ce championnat du monde
qui donc
est une aussi une de nos meilleures
joueuses françaises et qui donc fait un
match ici important pour son calendrier
2015 donc c'est parti avec irina crush
américaine qui a les blancs et hélas
cette fois là une partie très
différentes puisque on joue par on
commence par des quatre est en
couverture du pion dame qu'est les 6 et
4 e 6 câbles et c3 est ici sophie n'y
ait choisi le couffo b4 alors ça c'est
la fameuse de défense voyez donc en soi
ou estonienne swan in the witch après ça
dépend comment les noirs jouent enfin ça
s'appelle comme ça dans l'idée de ce
coût du développement du fou ici c'est
bien sûr de clouer le cavaly c3 le cas
les citrons peut pas bouger donc de
indirectement d'augmenter la pression
sur la case de 4 puisque le calice et 3
ne contrôle plus 4 munich louer et on
peut envisager de les changer aussi qui
fit le cavalier f6 contrôle bien eu
quatre donc on joue en général avec
l'idée b6 est foulé cette voie là on
augmente la pression sur quatre est
parfois les blancs jouent le coup et
trois rebonds va pas rentrer dans les
détails de cette ouverture que vous
pouvez étudier sur rodez bonal tv donc
ouest indienne ou nîmes the beach c'est
la même idée c'est le même développement
avec souvent les mains
c'est les mêmes conceptions c'est la
même idée du centre donc la dame ces
deux coups souple je protège le cavalier
je peux reprendre de la dame éviter un
doublement des pions et puis j'ai un
oeil sur la case de 4 la regarde et b6
voilà c'est l'idée qu'ont donné voilà
ton peu 4 bon pourquoi pas qu'à tout de
suite alors à noter que sur cas tout de
suite les noirs peuvent aussi jouer fou
prend et a obligé la reprise du pion
puisque si on prend de la dame
il y aurait cavaliers prend 2,4
donc c'est pas forcément une très bonne
idée de prendre de donner le fou tout de
suite comme ça parce qu'il ya après puis
on prend on a quand même un centre
blandford et on a donné un fou contre un
cavalier bon il faut faire attention à
ce fou b4 on le donne mais pas contre
rien contre les petites compensation ces
cinq voix la csn toujours dans l'idée à
noter en regarder dans ce type
d'ouverture les noirs et villetaneuse
jouer dès 5 ans joue pas même si c'est
parfois tentant on veut pas des simples
parce que eh bien les blancs on pourrait
jouer eu cinq attaques et le cavalier ou
s'éprend des cadets 5 ou et surtout on
veut pas loin des 5 boucher la démo
d'alcon a ouvert ici voila apres
s'éprend reprend et e5 bon quoique je
voulais noir le fou n'a plus d'intérêt à
venir en baisse est qu'il est bouchée
par son pion bon bref donc on joue
plutôt sur cases noires on joue ces cinq
parfois même au bout des six mêmes 5
parfois ça dépend des éclats bien sûr
voilà des cinq cubains impressions sur
le centre tout simplement des cinq ici
pour les blancs donc on évite la prison
joue des scènes soi même alors à noter
qu'en dessin bombay on a un centre for
sure cases blanches avec les pions mais
il est attaqué attaqué par le pion aux
six attaqué par le cavalier et 6 voilà
etc et potentiellement plus tard par le
fourbe et c'est tout parfois aussi par
le fou en a six parfois le fou à 6 ou
s'ils attaquent le pion c4 peut prendre
les 5 peut prendre d'essai - très
simplement il change et maintenant d'un
échec
pourquoi pas un échec
autrement normal cabaye est de 2 et la
b5
alors là aussi coup thématique un bon
alors l'un joue et b6 plus baissait mais
ça se justifie par les parce que le fait
de le fait que les blancs jouer des
scènes en jouant b celle qu'on affaiblit
c4 à noter d'ailleurs que le coup c'est
prendrait 5 et tout de suite puni par
cavalier prend des cinq puisque le
cannabis est roi et où et voilà le fou
ce qu'on appelle ici vise le roi ne peut
pas jouer ce cavalier donc b5 on
affaiblit c'est classique vous avez ici
ce qu'on appelle une chaîne de pions
encore une fois je vous ramène à
philidor analyse du jeu d'échecs la
reddition ou phil dent nous explique ça
dès le xviiie siècle les chaînes de
pions voilà le premier à avoir expliqué
ce concept on attaque la base
voilà on attaque la base de la chaîne
donc on l'affaiblît food et 2d comme les
blancs perdent pas de temps à jouer des
coups comme b3 dit ben beh si les blancs
les noirs près 1 perdent aussi perdre du
temps et c'est vrai aussi
et puis en plus on a des clous et le
cavalier ce qui fait que l'option des 5
est maintenant protégé en cas de prise
en c4 c'est pas vraiment un problème
parce que dès 5 est protégé par le câble
et c3 qui en plus peut être remplacé par
le cavalier e26 ont fait 40 par exemple
et c4 c5
ils sont tous ces quatre donc est un
pion doublé donc on n'aura pas de mal
avec le à le prendre le fouet feu le
vise déjà on voit que c'est un détail
d'aller chercher quoi ça va prendre
quelques coups mais on ne peut pas tenir
sa faune prend pourquoi pas il faut
penser 3 voilà on élimine le défenseur
de d5 et la faune princes et rois ça
c'est intéressant ça c'est inattendu
parce que évidemment on peut pas jouer
cavale epr en france et 3 bien sûr les
nord profitent du fait que les blancs
pas encore ok pour forcer ce trop
positif ou très certainement c'est ça
l'idée mais ce fouillis bien placés ici
tout de suite puisqu'il vise la
diagonale bon il peut être chassé par b
4 à tout moment mais si on joue b4 on
n'attaque plus la base et cette chaîne
de pions de main forte et
avantages et des inconvénients voilà
donc la petit rock de la part sophie
millet tranquillement on en croit pas et
grand que la position est équilibrée
très certainement ici avec des chances
des deux côtés et l'a alors bon on
pourrait s'attendre si de la part des
noirs sans doute un coup comme des pions
prend ses 4 semble quand même pas
mauvais ou b4 des quatre attaques le fou
avec un pion finalement bon mais pas
trop loin du roi blanc qui contrôle les
cases à 3 c3 en conjonction avec à 5 e
on pourrait envisager une petite attaque
de pions pour affaiblir le roi blanc
bon c'est des possibilités là sophie
millet joue cavalier e cas pourquoi pas
bon moi j'aime pas trop ce coup parce
que bon on rejoue le cavalier alors
qu'on a encore des pièces qui n'ont pas
joué mais bon pourquoi pas on attaque le
foot est roi c'est vrai aussi qu'on peut
menacer de gagner afin d'échanger
lecavalier contrefout et puis bon on a
aussi une menace
évidemment elle est très bien mais on
est sûr mais puisqu'on menace calais
prend avec deux attaques de tours bon
c'est quand même un coût un peu pénible
auxquelles il faut répondre au regard
des très jolies faut un train
tranquillement faut un j'enlève la
possibilité de les chambres et je
protégeais de t'être sophie a pas vu ce
qu'on sait que possible alors va pour
prendre ces quatre bons très bien si on
prend ces quatre bons l'idée c'est moins
de gagner un pion on sait qu'on ne
perdra que d'ouvrir une colonne sur le
roi ce roi a choisi le grand roque bon
très bien mais
dans ce cas là il ya quand même du jeu
cavaliers g3 de la part des blancs
tranquillement car les déciles semblent
bons coups très bien qu'elle ait des six
souvent bien de se mettre derrière un
pion puisque le cavalier pas attaquable
et en plus se regarder ce cavalier quand
même à protège ses quatre ce qui fait
que la reprise de ce procès quatre
devient problématique tout de suite
voilà mais bon le problème c'est que
l'option 17 gêne les noirs et on n'a pas
joué en d6 donc le fou c'est 8 est
bloqué bon il pourrait venir un bep
cette taxe et chatouiller des 5 c'est
possible ou voir un assist pour
surprotéger c4 pourquoi pas mais dans ce
cas-là commençant le cavalier vite alors
dix cavaliers
si on forme et le fond à six qu'elle ne
peut pas mener en dix-sept peut pas
venir à ces six peut pas venir assister
fait qu'on a deux pièces enfermé c'est
pas bon on pourrait jouer d'abord cahier
à 6 ans visant b4 certainement et les
blancs pertes perdent pas de temps son
coin entendu tout à fait raison
puisqu'ils font fou prend ses quatre
caves et les princes et 4 dames prend
ses 4
des six voilà maintenant c'est l'heure
pour l'épauler noir pourquoi pas après
d'emprunt ces cas de jouer des sens
c'est bien position équilibrée à choisir
ici je dirais même que je préfère
légèrement les noirs puisque on a quand
même ici bon bain au roi blanc qui
semblent moins bien protégés que le roi
noir pourquoi regarder ici on a trois
pions blancs face à trois boutons noirs
donc ce qui fait qu'il ya pas de colonne
contre le roi noir
là il ya une colonne ici suis dit c'est
pas ça pas semble pas non plus un
avantage crucial parce que le fou 1 1
sera magnifiquement se placer en c3
puisque à la fois il protègera b2 donc
rendra quand même à difficile la taxe
sur la colonne et en plus il vise g7
voilà sans réel danger pour les noirs
tout de suite mais ça peut être embêtant
on est envisagé c'est notamment le cas
des lits peuvent venir h5 avec attac
double attaque
si les noirs sont obligés de jouer g6
tout est faible tout ça fait bidon coin
voilà donc attention
et quand même potentiel d'attac non pas
sur l'icône pour les blancs mais sur les
diagonales
voilà ce qui fait que je compense la
position quand même très équilibré et
des contres chances des deux côtés ou c3
justement calais 17 semble beaucoup un
lecavalier va pouvoir envisager de venir
soit on arrive six pour venir pourquoi
pas en 8 plus tard pour protéger quoique
lent il ya la colonne qu'il permettra
des sacrifices ce n'est pas une bonne
idée mais où venir en simple pourquoi
pas mais bon c'est de ces cas sont pas
très très bon de toute façon pour les
noirs puisque même en 1-5
il ya f4 qui tôt ou tard permettra de
chasser ce cavalier
mais bon alors il notre idée c'est de
venir peut-être plus c'est plus l'idée
d'ailleurs je pense devenir en b6
attaque la dame et b5 et des scènes
pardon ce qui fait qu'on peut mettre une
pression sur le pion des 5 ce qui serait
une très bonne idée une bonne nouvelle
pour les noirs de pouvoir attaquer des
500 obligerait les blancs à le défendre
et donc faire autre chose que de
chercher une attaque contre les noirs
tour à chaud entre logique sort la
dernière pièce qui joue pas en attaquant
la dame d'alger cinq échecs évite de
perdre du temps mais f4 a alors lâché 4
et c'est un bon coup pour l'épauler
blanc puisqu'on on a vu que eh bien ça
empêche cac valeo 5
de toute façon donc tôt ou tard sans
doute les blancs ont été obligés de le
jouer donc là on essaie de ne pas perdre
de temps non plus et là sophie joue
claval ib 6ième alors l'accabler bicis
pourquoi pas
sa contre attaque la dame blanche au
moment où la dame noire est attaqué bon
une autre possibilité quand même ici
aurait été de jouer plus de façon plus
calme plus tranquille un coup comme dame
g4 pourquoi dame jkd pour garder la dame
de ce côté là en défense notamment de g7
et c'est difficile d'attaquer cette dame
puisque l'on peut pas jouer h3 à cause
du cavaly g3 qui emprise et en ayant la
dame acheter on peut pas non plus jouer
f celle qu'avait l'idée de jouer six
pour affaiblir les noix puisqu'il y
aurait vis-à-vis d'am-dam donc la dame
avait l'air bien au g4 aussi bon ça
permettait de recettes par contre de
recettes on n'aime pas avoir une tour
adverse sur la 7e c'est sûr bon pourquoi
pas quand même bon mais qu'elle
épaississe semble un peu pesci d'autant
que les blancs saute sur l'occasion pour
faire quand même
puis on prend j 5 alors qu en convient
les blancs ici sur peut-être certaines
précisions noirlac avec les six car les
princes et 4 et là regardez simplement
tour quatre cahiers de bouger quel et b6
donc pourquoi tour 4 bien tord car je
peux envisager avec la tour plus tard
devenir pourquoi pas 1 h 4
mais sa menace rien tout seul ici mais
pourquoi pas surtout de doubler les
tours voilà pourrait doubler les tours
mais on peut pas là avec le câble est
indécise puisque le pion de dessins qui
seront prises si on double les tours on
ferait simplement calais point des 5
on met la tour est quand même plus à
petit 24 quand même donc tout re cat
qu'elle et b6 et la cave alliage 5 voilà
comme ça c'est l'idée qu'on me disait
tout à l'heure
bon c'est moins grave que quand la dame
est il et dames sont là et regardez
justement avec la dame henri iv en
empêcher ce phénomène avant la kabylie h
singles problèmes n'ont rien et c'est ça
ça attaque les deux cas on me dit c'est
pas grave je joue que j'ai six matches
ici c'est grave parce que si les noirs
jouent ici le coup g6
le fou contrôle regardez y suivre et
simplement gabriel six échecs le roi
bien par exemple angers7
et maintenant ah ben tiens par exemple
typiquement la up tour h théâtre menace
maths mais même sans ça regardez le
cavaly s'il viendrait en dix-sept échec
du fou fameux échec à la découverte on
vient d'en avoir plein dans la partie de
marie ces vagues cavaliers des sept
échecs du fou le roy doc protéger cet
échec par exemple revenir en 8es
simplement prend la tour et on a gagné
une qualité et très certainement la
partie d'envoyer le problème de ce coup
cavaliers h5 semble-t-il a été
totalement ignoré pas vu de la part de
de la part de se finir et là on a un
problème
alors si on jouait f6 s'ils ont joué 6
c'est possible aussi
sait on de voir ça m6 est une autre
possibilité d'accord
donc la scala y aurait simplement g
prend m6 est évidemment si on prend et
bien on peut tout simplement
on peut aussi venir faire tourner tout
aux 7 avec une tour sur la 7ème et on
peut prendre six avec échecs et les
noirs sont quand même dans la panade
donc c'est pas bon voilà donc la mélisse
semblerait que ce coup que les v6 soit
une faute tout simplement
voilà le coup pas ici mais là dans cette
position le coup souhaitable sans doute
ici soit dame jesse soit plutôt même
dame g4 à moi j'aime bien ce coup dame
g4 bon même si mes sûr il ya encore des
plaines coût pour les blancs possèdent
améliorer leur position mais bon ça
cette dame quand même empêché les blancs
de faire ce qu'il voulait sur les droits
c'est cette dame aussi défendre on
aurait pu céder finir son développement
avec les noirs calais b 6 permet cette
manoeuvre est franc j'ai calé conséquent
tour 4 est déjà ça semble difficile fou
et cinq bons attaque la tour déjà un
bateau avec a tout simplement voilà que
font les noirs fou g6 bon pourquoi pas
mais la voilà qu'à aller prendre un set
c'est terminé on a gagné un pion on a
gagné un pion et en plus on a d'autres
qui ont doublé
regardez en plus maintenant les blancs
rêve que d'une chose c'est que ce pion
h4 viendra ch 5 et tout est attaqué le
cavaly protégeant h5
ça fait des pions qui attaquent le roi
risque d'être attaqué voyez même sens
les dames il peut y avoir des attaques
sur le roi très dangereuse donc là il
semblerait que quand même là ça sera
quand même un peu difficile alors c'est
4 de la part de sophie alors l'idée de
ce coup probablement simplement c4 c'est
de protéger la cage afin d'avoir une
case en d3 le caler le pion protège la
case d3 donc le fou en cas d' h 4 h
c'est le four à une case de sauvegarde
sinon il y en a pas en fait regardez
imaginé ce pion en cinq nouvelles fou si
la passion il est mort donc en jouant
des trois je me préserve la possibilité
food et 3 pour sauver le fou
kovalev 5 et là problème menace matin
recettes matin à 6h ce matin puisque le
fou contrôler toutes les autres cases
magnifique un donc sa force la prise et
blanc sont obligés de prendre pour
preuve cinq tours f18 à sophie veut
activer ses tours c'est normal les tours
pour l'instant n'était pas active tour
des f1 attention pression sur f7 c'est
facile tour cette voie là tranquillement
en plus je prépare - même le doublement
des tours h théâtre c'est ce qu'on avait
dit on à un pion de plus mais ce pion
est doublé voyez où ses débuts en fait
c'est le pongiste celle qui en plus si
vous voulez il est doublé
mais les noirs ceci dit an d'option
isolé bon et si on veut essayer d'en
profiter quand même il va falloir
attaquer ce roi noir alors on va essayer
d'attaquer ce roi noir pourquoi pas oui
je pense que c'est une bonne idée
d'attaquer avec les pions puisque le fou
ici est tellement puissant que l'on peut
même avoir un réseau de maths
si en août d'une colonne aux mines
colonnes une tour sur la colonne h on va
ensuite seimat
voyez donc ce genre d'idées ça peut
faire mal tours s'est vite h5 on est
continuelle continue le plan cavalia 4
et à quatre menaces d'échangés ce fou
qui est magnifique un devoir
il est superbe donc les blancs laisse
pas faire fou si ces tours 2 alors
l'aidera aussi j'ai trouvé de contrôle
de c'est pas mal c'est bien vu attaque
j'ai deux contre attaques méfiez vous
mais méfions-nous des contre attaques
en l'occurrence espérons que la contre
attaque de sophie fonctionne ici on est
supporter de des françaises ce qui est
mon cas donc évidemment natale g2 on
commence à attaquer un peu b2 il ya ces
trois qui peut venir à on se dit ça ya
un petit peu de contrôle jeu même si on
voit bien que le jeu blanc extrêmement
puissant là mais attention parfois quand
on a les yeux au menu billet vers l'
attaque on sous estime les contres
chance et derrière on se fait
la position se fait retourner se
retourne up donc défense voilà
tranquillement irina crush prend pas de
risque simplement la vue qui avait du
potentiel
elles elles échangent une pièce d'attac
tour en tour prend voyez comme se
pressent pas et qu'elles évitent de
foncer dans son plan yeux fermés car les
v6 attaques des cinq une des faiblesses
du camp du camp blanc à noter que ça
paraît pas malsain parce que regarder la
tour c 8 peut venir en c5 aussi
attaquant desseigne deux fois comment
les blancs peuvent défendre deux fois
deux fois des 5 c ça semble impossible
tollefsen quand même on protège ici n 5
voilà pourquoi pas tour c'est simple
quoi alors c'est possible et c'est on le
voir mais c'est pas ce qu'a fait sophie
up
pour ses 5 voilà
c'est de refaire ça de façon plus
insistants d'art pourquoi
alors tu es faire
non je vais
je puis voilà
voilà c'est pas comme je voulais donc
ici tour c5 est possible on est d'accord
attaque deux fois à des 5
ça paraît très bien alors l'idée c'est
peut-être de jouer food et 4,1 d'accord
ou des quatre ici puisque fou attaque la
tour attaque le cavalier est à 7 ce qui
fait qu'en cas de prise en d5
simplement on prendrait et après calais
prend on prend à cette donc on récupère
le pion mais il y avait des chances ici
que les f4 est jouable
bon attention le pion à est passé et le
fou est toujours supérieure dans ce type
de situation
quand tu as des pions des deux côtés
avec un autre en actions passées le fou
à la fois peut protéger l avance du pur
on est attaqué de l'autre côté le
seeland des cartes qui protège à 7 et en
même temps ils contrôlent des cases du
côté des hôtes payants alors que
lecavalier 6 pro tail empêche le pion
d'avancé il est coincé là et pareil pour
le roi s'il est coincé là le rôle blanc
lui il peut aller où il veut voilà ce
qui fait que la position est sans doute
techniquement perdante aussi ça c'est
quand même embêtant donc tour f 5 tours
8 choisit donc sophie minet qui a dû
évaluer cette finale en dix ans et
perdant roi des 2 tours 4 4 c'est une
bonne idée
l'idée de 112 2 tours 4 c'est devenir
peut sans doute ans j'ai quatre
attaquants g2 forçant les blancs à
revenir en f2 et dans ce cas là à
dessein qui a perdu donc 3 c3 c'est
possible
voilà
ici cavaliers à 4 de sophie très
intéressante puisque ben attention ce
cavalier attaque le roi si le roi vient
en b 4 on peut jouer ses trois avec
échec de la tour qui attaquent le roi et
protège le cavalier par transparence le
pion ces trois étant protégé le roi
bouger en pillant prend b2 et c est plus
la même
c'est plus la même partie du tout donc
attention la rue des deux semble forcer
pour empêcher tour deux échecs et la
cale et b6 toujours pareil on revient
donc le roi le roi peut pas venir en c3
en fait on peut pas venir augmenter
l'attaqué et cavagnan b6 j'ai toujours
un oeil sur le pion des scènes je menace
tôt que j'ai 4 attention donc j'ai 3
alors pourquoi j'ai 3 après tour j'ai
quatre attaques g3 mais il n'y a pas
d'échec en cas de prise y aurait pas
d'échec bon ça c'est une première chose
et en plus les blancs jouent simplement
tour f3 pourquoi pas mais ça y est
sophie revient un peu dans la partie
avec cavaliers prendre des 5
voilà ça y est le pion a été récupéré et
l'avantagé sans doute un peu moins fort
du côté blanc donc avec et voyez comme
avec de l'opiniâtreté ici et bien sophie
millet arrive à équilibrer le jeu tu
sans doute peut-être toujours une
position un peu inférieur à cause
toujours pareil de la prééminence du fou
sur le cavalier fou qui attaquent des
deux côtés quoique bon lancement ça ne
paraît pas très latin cette finale a en
tout cas voilà alors tour à 3 de la part
des rinne a crush très intéressant bien
sûr puisque le pion à 7 est faible si je
prends un set je me crée un pion passé
as toujours bien à vendre qui ont passé
et qui plus est si j'ai un pion pas
s'éloigner c'est pas mal parce que quand
je le pousse ça oblige les pièces à
s'éloigner du jeu voilà hélas alors là
ici
qu'est ce que les noirs auraient pu
jouer
qu'avaient les problèmes si ça paraît
bien donc sophie millet jukka les
problèmes 6 g prend m6 bon alors c'est
intéressant puisque on élimine le fou
contre le cabba et on a dit que le fouet
et souvent supérieurs en finale ce qui
est souvent vrai et en plus il ya le
fameux adage les finales de tours sont
toujours nul à la finale deux tours sont
toujours nue alors là le problème si
vous voulez c'est que le pion ici c'est
très fort puisque regarder les sauts qf6
fait comme si le g7 était encore là
puisque le roi ne peut pas venir en g7
donc il ya un math du couloir le mât du
couloir donne un temps supplémentaire
aux blancs sur quand je vais prendre à
cette gymnaste matt donc à 7 est
virtuellement perdu avec un temps de
plus et donc j'aurai toujours j'ai
toujours potentiellement un pion de plus
un point de plus et je vais avoir un
pion passé en finale le tour et puis on
passe et c'est crucial pour déterminer
qui a l'avantagé qu'il a pas donc ici en
plus donc faut protéger le mode du
couloir donc h si ça oblige à jouer un
coup de
ashes beaucoup d'attentes qui est pas
terrible parce que regarder après tout
reprend à 7
bon et bien le roi n'est plus mat mais
il le seul kasugho pour aller ch 7 et il
est toujours enfermé il est sur le côté
est enfermé bon on prend à angers 3
quand même à mesure il faut récupérer
très vite maintenant tour échec pourquoi
après rouages 7 simplement touriste 8
voilà ça récupère le cuir et vii donc là
problème pour les noirs j'ai le pion f
qui est passée potentiellement puisque
c'est d'eux va tomber 18 le pur ake pa
c'est aussi ça fait deux
et non on n'a toujours pas on peut
prendre hashtag vous me direz oui mais
ça va être long d'amore ça prend
plusieurs coups est bon alors vous me
direz le pion de dépasser c'est vrai le
pion de dépasser mais le roi est devant
lui alors que la de voir le pion à
illiers pas laurent il est très loin de
l'autre côté en fait voyez la différence
est de qualité donc les blancs toujours
davantage alors ses trois échecs
intéressant alors très bien ça delhi les
pions il faut savoir qu'en finale deux
tours si vous avez deux pions liées est
passé certes irruption c4 est pris plus
tard deux pions lee est passé c'est
gagnant ça gagne tout le temps j'ai même
passé il faut y font jouer pour
comprendre pourquoi c'est infernal
alors ces trois échecs ça ça oblige les
blancs à reprendre du pied voilà et on a
cassé là
la liaison des pions et en plus après la
tour j'ai deux voilà ces jolis plans des
trois tours 3 2 on a éliminé le pion
passé éloignés comme sophie millet fait
attention
elle a bien elle a bien joué et
stratégiquement ici en éliminant le pion
le plus dangereux voilà pour prendre cet
échec au roi g8 tour j'ai cet échec
pourquoi pas les fuites tout âge 7 et
voilà le pion aux 6es perdu aussi c'est
pénible ça coûte cher ça finit par
coûter cher tour h 2 pourquoi pas tout
reprend 1,6 et 1,7 alors c'est
intéressant brader parce que la tour la
bon elle protège m6 mais dès qu'elle
bouge m6 est perdu voilà parce que le
roi l'a donc autant le roi blanc et le
roi noir et ait pris autant la tour
blanche est prise au syli voyez donc les
noces se défendent bien là quand même
faut savoir les finales tour sont
toujours nul on dit ça veut dire qu'en
fait c'est très dur à gagner car même
quand on a deux points de plus ils sont
pas liées s'ils sont liés c'est très
gagnant mais même quand son pallier
certaines positions sont entendues aussi
et avec un pion de plus il sa dépense il
y à la position définie doit ou pas donc
c'est des choses qu'il faut connaître
parce que si vous savez pas trop à un
moment donné l'aubade échanges pour
passer dans la bonne finale qui vous
assurent soit là nul si vous cherchez la
nuls soit la victoire si vous chercher
la victoire si vous connaissez pas la
technique qui permet de gagner et bien
vous allez pas savoir conclure des
parties roi des quatre donc très bien on
avance le roi a regardé comme le roi
dans toutes les finales
on l'a vu avec marie sebag aussi le roi
joue un rôle décisif comme ya plus de
maths
disons forcé il ya eu une attaque de
maths violente en finale et tout ça le
roi peut subir des échecs mais c'est
jamais décisif c'est toujours pour
essayer de le repousser justement même
si une pièce d'attac tour des deux
échecs très bien obligera sekkat donc le
roi est obligé de venir devant son pion
et on revient h2 pourquoi pas voilà et
la bombe et les blancs ben si il font
garder 5
bah je sais pas je suppose qu'on peut
jouer encore ton des deux échecs voilà
donc qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
les noirs il faudrait arriver très
certainement à échanger le pion 2d
contre le pion sait si on arrivait à ça
je pense que ça on devrait arriver à
faire nul parce que la tour il m'a placé
dès qu'elle bouge le pion m6 est perdu
est un pion à cheveux ça gagne pas en
finale deux tours
le roi est bien placé vis à vis de ses
deux pions mais il est mal placé
vis-à-vis du pion c'est donc pensé et l'
avantage des blancs plus que les deux
autres pions la torah suite
bon alors là les blancs décide de deux
séries de passes et de bousculer la
partie en donnant le plus réussi cela
comprend très bien et maintenant justice
alors attention à 6 puis sa menace h7
mais achètent et pas une vraie menace
après tout vu en g7 tour bouge et je
prends h cette voie là alors après la
question c'est est-ce qu'en finale je
vais arriver à soit gardé le pion des
six ce qui serait merveilleux soit si je
le perds est-ce que j'arriverai dans la
position de philidor qui permet de faire
nul sinon j'ai perdu alors tour d2 voilà
il faut garder ce plan très certainement
je suis pas sûr soit forcément le bon
coup ici quand même à l'orage si si si
probablement roger 6 pourquoi pas roger
6 alors essayons de voir ce qui peut se
passer
roy g6 d'accord attaque le pion à 6 est
ce que c'est une vraie attaque même pas
parce que si je cite ou reprend tout
reprend au roi prend trois des cinq
s'est perdu donc c'est une attaque
bon ça n'empêche pas les blancs si les
blancs jours à des singles et peut-être
tout simplement on fait trois tours
tours d2 et sheva la wii après avec
château en fait on va jouer contre le
bras blancs hélas ici c'est si les
blancs s'en vont on prend le pion à 6 et
si le poussons joue roger cette tour
bouger et simplement
on prendra le pion à vii quelque chose
comme ça bon roi g6 était possible bon
alors sur h6 ici autour des 2 bon
pourquoi pas c'est qu'ils se trouvent
les bons coups c'est très difficile à
c'était très technique c'est de la
finale donc c'est difficile de fond
d'analyser tous les coups avec beaucoup
de profondeur donc tour g8
attention menace h 7 h les contours un
peu forcé tondez 8
attention maintenant surtout reprend
tout reprend michel roy tous reprendront
après la finale perdue parce que le roi
est trop loin j'avance avec le roi tak
tak et ensuite le pion c'est à une voie
royale pour les ferda bleu noir les
noirs peuvent pas l'arrêter
testez-les sur un échiquier où vous
allez voir tour prend un tour pranger
change et vous verrez que le pion blanc
est inarrêtable
il faut surtout pas faut jouer pour
larsen très bien hélas tous âges suite
d'orages théâtre échec robe et 5 très
bien on rate des cinq des 5 g parce que
c'est très bon h 7 h tête attention si
le roi maintenant revient sur la colonne
eux il y aura tour échec et dames et en
plus si maintenant les blancs jouent aux
échecs on pourra pas faire tout reprend
parce que si on fait tout reprendre en
enlève la possibilité de contrôler le
pion il suffira de vous la tour
n'importe où ici on 8 par exemple et on
peut pas empêcher à 8 h 8 dames donc
attention h7
là ça devient tendu
les noirs ont été un peu sous-évalué ici
mais attention on est embêté note aussi
dans cette finale donc les coûts
forcément sont aussi sous la pression du
temps donc sont moins précis tour h5 abc
ce tour h61 bombay pourquoi pas en
protège des six
ces quatre échecs mais sa paire le pion
mais non ça perd pas le pion puisque si
roy prend évidemment la tour échec suite
dame
je reprends et après avec troyes et
tours le pion des et facilement arrêté
il est trop loin de dames pour menacer
quoi que ce soit et le roi blanc est
trop près de lui donc israël sera un
ange et et la finale sera perdu trois
décades donc forcé on essaie en ga en
joue le roi où on évite aux blancs de
pouvoir faire échec si on avait joué le
roi dans la colonne c'est pareil on se
prenait un échec subite d'un roi b5
d'orage cinq échecs on avait quatre
tours h 1 alors regardez autour des 8
et voilà ça y est une magnifique ça
c'est très joli ce dernier coup tripoli
menace dame alors ça c'est un coup
champion d'un coup de grands maîtres
tranquillement on donne le pion rage
contre le pion des pourquoi parce
qu'après tout reproche cette tour prend
des six soirs d ici il ya la fameuse
opposition des rois sur échec il faut
que le roi noir s'en aille
n'importe où par an 1,5 et après ces
cinq simplement regarder ce roi est
coupée la tour compte trois hommes la
colonne des donc le pion c'est va
pouvoir avancer sans le roi qui pourra
jamais passer cette colonne et cette
finale est techniquement gagner on peut
pas obtenir la fameuse position définie
dehors pour avoir la position de fils
d'or qui permet d'assurer la nulle au
noir il faut que l'on aura nord arrive
tôt ou tard à se mettre d'eux voir le
pion voilà devant le pion et donc sinon
il y a toujours une série de
du coup blanc qui permet d'assurer la
victoire alors c'est parfois techniques
et des subtilités mais les grands
maîtres con et ça par coeur ils sont
obligés ça parce que c'est si on sait
pas jouer ces finales par coeur on peut
pas espérer gagner un tournoi c'est pas
possible donc tomber cet échec
voilà c'est tranquillement voir dès que
les blancs pas peur parce qu'en fait le
pion tôt ou tard va avancer à pas tout
de suite la tour sera en prise mais le
pion va avancer et la tour de bras à
l'arrêter donc le roi pourra revenir sur
la colonne b plus quand il veut tomber
un ouais on pourra pas vous ne peut pas
faire beaucoup d'échecs vous allez voir
tour d2 si on fait échec mais trois des
six héros échec mais on va on sait 7
devant le pion et après on pousse on
pousse avec le roi s'est vite et comme
le roi noir est loin il est coupé en dit
qu'il est coupé on ne peut pas empêcher
la victoire
6 ces six annassers 7 s'est vite il faut
faire quelque chose
raul7 c7 alors la menace damas un emploi
il faut vite faire avant là ça y est
c'est leur tour c'est un gros v6 tomber
rishek roi cette menace dam tour c'est
un droit mais cette tourbe est un échec
roy s'est vite alors on peut se dire ben
c'est bien pour les noirs puisque là à
regarder les blancs peuvent pas bouger
effectivement je suis coincé sur la
colonne ici par la tour et là par le roi
noir c'est vrai mais regardez c'est
maintenant la force et la technique
sophie millet joue un coup d'attentes
normal mais regardez la technique des
grands tours aux deux échecs et là le
roi avait être obligé de partir encore
plus loin parce que sylvie anne decis ce
roi ben on va le montrer tout simplement
alors problème eux deux alors
voilà
si le roi noir vient en d6 avec j'ai
coupé la colonne des dons qu'il suffit
que la maintenant avec les blancs jouent
simplement roi des huit voies là et ce
qu'ils on va aller à dame au prochain
coup donc la tour sera obligée sans
doute devenir en ces trois dames tout
reprend droit prend héros et au vous
savez que ça gagnait ça me de le savoir
si vous ne savez pas folle à prendre
donc tours 8
alors attendez je revienne à
l'opposition donc ici sur toro deux
échecs dont vient pas en d6 à cause de
roide et vite
on est obligé donc de partir et si on
part regardez ici avec la tour qui est
là c'est magnifique on a le roi noir qui
maintenant encore plus loin du pion il
est à deux colonnes voilà c'est un
critère de gain à leurs tours 8
magnifique tour 8 menace 3,17 d'accord
et latour protège la dame donc si les
noirs font échec au mans c'est si c'est
encore un échec on va enlever cet échec
après on monte tac en attaque la tour
sur la colonne a et b et on peut pas en
une fois que la tour sera en prise avec
le roi elle pourra plus empêcher ces
huit dames voilà donc ici la menace
c'est 3 17 milliards il ya possibilité
de jouer le roi et vii ellaroys 17
screen faute puisque ce roi des 7 je
joue tour huit échecs roi bouge to
riches cheikhs et si le roi revient 17
ya perpétuelle on est maintenant mais il
ya le coup gagnant après droit et 7 qui
est fort ses torts quatre coups de
grands maîtres à la menace ccem ses
tours ses 4 qui sera jouée plus tard
voilà donc on va je vais vous montrer
une marine de variantes ici après
simplement tours d'eau 4 voilà eh bien
les noirs pour y jouer alors n'importe
quoi par exemple relève 6 1 voilà si je
reviens et 8 je reviendrai fils est
c'est vrai problème est là maintenant le
coup gagnant ses trois des sept
alors pourquoi parce que bon les morts
non comme défense que de faire des
échecs alors échec
on vient ici échec et puis on se dit ben
il peut pas la tour peut pas venir
protéger
ouais ouais sauf que ça marche pas
regardez simplement on joue roi je crois
que c'est wade ci soit la voie des six
et là c'est fini
pourquoi parce que la menace s'est tous
remis huit on est d'accord protège
empêche la dame
bon et si les noirs font encore un échec
elle a maintenant vian c5
c'est ça l'idée c'est pour ça que la
tour vient ou 4 voilà pourquoi parce que
maintenant sur les check up ça y est on
bien tour et le royer pourquoi c'est
important d'avoir le roi un peu loin
voilà le roi étant un peu loin c'est
fini un code tout reprend après c'est
fini la dame ne peut pas être empêchées
c'est ça l'idée
voilà donc la échec là et s'ils allaient
noir joue un coup comme leroy f 7 par
exemple pour empêcher tout ruiner et
bien simplement qu est-ce que ce qui
doit devenir simplement tour 5 pour la
taureau 5 gagne maintenant on vient aux
5 vient d'abord un gars voient là
puisque là le roi peut toujours pas
venir et le prochain coup ça sera tour
c5
voilà et là ça y est le roi est protégé
par la tour donc et donc ses gagnants
voilà donc après on fêtera et 7 retours
e cat surtour cassou fumier abandonne
malheureusement cette première manche
donc avec les noirs elle a perdu mais
elle aura quand même les blancs dans la
deuxième partie donc elle peut revenir
au score dans ce premier tour de
championnat du monde voilà donc voilà
pour cette première ronde du championnat
du monde féminin on a vu deux partis les
deux parties de nos françaises marie
sebag et sophie millet avec donc ce
résultat
bien extrêmement positif pour marie
c'est bas qui mène donc 2 fois face à
young et sophie millet qui s'est fait
par contre battre avec les noirs par
irina crèche voilà merci à bientôt pour
la suite de ce championnat du monde 2015
féminin à sotchi en russie
au revoir